before we get started i feel the need to
remind you that the news arm of the bbc
ran a quote-unquote article on trans
women containing misleading information
and provable falsehoods as well as
platforming a woman who then went on to
make a literal call for the genocide of
trans women and while that individual's
comments have been stricken from the
article the bbc has yet to address the
fact that they platformed her and has
not disavowed or condemned her
statements
you can find links in a pinned comment
below for relevant videos if you do not
know what i'm talking about that being
said
on with the show
okay
at this point i i just have one question
out of all the plots currently going on
which one's the main one
[Music]
[Music]
doctor who flux survivors of the flux
i'm going to try and
not get as worked up
on this one as last one
i
i i feel a little bit frustrated with
some of the comments that went on the
last one that seemed to suggest that i
was going in looking to not like it
first of all i'll point out i was
actually quite hopeful for the previous
episode because i'd liked war of the
santorins and village of the angels
looked like it was going to be more
stand alone the way that was and it
was for about half the episode and then
it it very much wasn't
but
i don't feel like i'm doing that
i'm not enjoying it for the most part
that much is true and i'm not going to
suddenly pretend that my opinion isn't
my opinion
but i will try and not get
excessively negative on this simply for
the sake of
just trying to find the good in it
i don't know how much there is
that's not to say that a ton of is bad
but a lot of it is just
kind of there
and that wasn't really a joke
that opening thing
because at this point
we have
had
three
villains who could in any other story be
the primary villains introduced
and we've got multiple story lines going
on and i don't know what one's the main
one right now the only thing we have an
answer to
is where the flux came from and why
kind of so
i'm getting into spoilers right off
it's a it's a serialized thing like i
fee i feel like you should know that but
there's your warning
so we now know
the division created the flux
and the flux
exists
simply because
the doctor existing in the universe as
we know it
throws the division's plans off too much
in a very vaguely defined way something
about the doctor generating too much
hope
no real explanation as to why that is
such a problem especially when the
doctor has not consciously been aware of
how any of this in fact impacts the
division at all but we now have a point
of origin for the flux
and we meet um
techtayoon
who was the person from galifrey who
originally discovered the doctor
with the doctor being the timeless child
so everyone who put forth the theory
that the master was lying
uh in that entire thing
that's now gone i always assumed that
that was never going to be the case
simply because it negates the entire
use or whatever the use was supposed to
be of the timeless child reveal if the
next time it comes up you're just gonna
go no that wasn't real that's the
definition of a
plot cul-de-sac it went in a circle but
ultimately ended up going nowhere
so i didn't think that was going to be
the case and we now know it isn't that
having been said it still hasn't gone
much of anywhere because you bring in
someone who
you play like a big deal
someone who we don't really know have
only has only ever been talked about
before
that the score and the framing of the
show makes that makes out like it's a
big deal
and then kills
uh and kills by means of what looked
like the initial primary antagonist
which was swarm in azul
i assume see like i assumed at the
beginning that those were gonna
ultimately be our primary antagonist and
maybe for the next
the last episode of this maybe they
still will be except that there's been a
big diversion and they haven't felt like
the primary antagonist they've just kind
of been there and we still don't really
know what they're doing we still don't
really have
that firm an idea of why the division
had to stop them in the first place
it's all been done in very vague terms
like we know that they were a threat to
the planet time but we don't really know
why or what that meant or what they were
hoping to accomplish it's all been dealt
with and talked about in very broad very
vague terms but because they killed tech
tyoon which
at least for me carries very little
impact because while this is a character
who was talked about before it was
effectively only one time before it's
somebody who i don't have a lot of
investment in
but they kill her
so i guess now they're the primary
antagonist by default except the flux
wasn't created by them
so it's just happening at the same time
at least as presented so far
by sheer coincidence
the flux is happening at the same time
they are getting out at the same time as
whatever the heck the grand serpent is
which is another thing this is another
character that in
most other stories i would assume to be
the primary antagonist
except here he's just layered in with
everybody else
and i don't know how he ties into
anybody else if he does at all
they have tied him into the santarans
who i thought we were done with
i don't necessarily have a problem with
them coming back i again i liked war of
the santorins
but
suddenly they're coming back which is
one more thing that this finale is going
to have to deal with so honestly the
question for me at this point
is less
how is this last episode gonna possibly
tie all these loose ends up and more how
many of these loose ends is it either
not gonna bother tying up at all or is
it going to
kick to address in the next couple of
specials that we know jodie whittaker is
doing before she actually leaves the
part
um because i
all right let me let me put it this way
if
the last episode of doctor who flux
attempts to tie up all of the loose ends
and unanswered questions that currently
exist
about the doctor about the swarm and
azul about the grand serpent about what
division is doing
about um the joe martin the fugitive
doctor about how the santarins are going
to be dealt with once they come back up
if it's going to address all of that
then it's not really going to have much
of an actual plot is going to be an
exercise largely in
narrative
loose end tying and i would be shocked
if there is much of an actual plot to it
outside of that the episode i tend to
reference for that kind of thing is the
big bang which a lot of people like and
i don't i like uh the pandorica opens
very much i don't like the big bang this
was the uh series five um
finale
with matt smith and the reason i don't
like the big bang is because it feels
much more like an exercise in tying up
plot holes than it does like an actual
story in and of itself it feels like
what story there is is being driven by
the need for what storylines do we need
to tie up and less by what is a good
story to tell
and i feel like if the finale of flux is
going to try and tie everything off it's
going to feel like that but worse
because it's got way more and much more
significant things to try and tie up
and at this point
this this series is already
demonstrating a propensity for just
dropping plot lines the incident doesn't
have a use for them within this episode
itself the fact that we open
in 1904 three years after uh yaz
uh jericho and dan were stranded in 1901
and don't explain how they ever got out
of that village
because unless i missed something
which i'm open to it's possible i'm
human i'm a human with adhd so it is
possible but
i don't remember them resolving a
the fact that that entire town that they
were in was taken out of time and space
like not only was it sort of
free-floating in this weird time space
bubble but that seemed to be encroaching
in
and now suddenly that isn't the case
anymore and suddenly the young girl that
they were protecting
is not something that we're worrying
about anymore
now is it completely impossible to make
some leaps about that that maybe after
the angels
got hold of the doctor for the division
they put the town back
and that
these people dropped off peggy i think
her name was somewhere to be raised no
that's not an impossible leap to make
but those are some pretty big leaps that
you're asking us to make given that
given just that
why would the angels
put the town back
i mean they they were reveling in their
own cruelty by the end there they made
clear they like to mess with people so
it's not like they're the type who would
just put everything back the way it was
once they got what they wanted
they would have kept messing with them
at least that to me makes more sense to
the characterization we were given than
just they put it back
and
while i don't necessarily have a problem
with leaping forward if the things that
we're leaping past are the natural
logical things that like okay well we
definitely know that this would happen
in the interim so it's fine there are
ways to make a leaping a leap forward in
time work on that basis but i don't
think it does in this case because we're
just
leaping over massive questions of
how are you even alive right now
and i don't think you can really just
gloss over
what happened to that little kid
and
we got through the episode and i was
expecting
some
tossed off conversational line
between yaz and dan and jericho just
noting something explaining something
and honestly i might have been okay with
that i've said in the past that i
actually appreciate often if something
isn't really worth devoting a ton of
time to a tossed off line even a casual
one to just cover the whole real quick
to make it clear that yes we understand
that this is a thing this is our
band-aid over it let's move on because
it's not that important i'm totally fine
with that it's a practice but we don't
even get that
we don't even get an acknowledgement
that
what the heck happened
how did we get here
and the the errands that the doctor has
them running on
feel
well first of all they feel like busy
work and they feel kind of arbitrary
like
the doctor makes a wild guess that
various people cultures whatever would
have somehow
picked up a
psychic essence to know when the world's
gonna end
which
okay i guess i get i i don't know i
don't know why as a plot point i don't
like that like i honestly don't
something about that i just don't like
maybe it's too close to
just prophecy in general and i don't
like prophecy and
faded outcomes and stuff like that maybe
it's just brushing up too close to that
um
i will say that when they went up the
mountain uh to meet the seer
that was cute
i
i did like that i like the idea that
this that he's just happy to mess with
people because he sees people so really
like this is my chance to mess with
people so i just i'm just gonna mess
with you a little bit
i kind of liked him
and performance wise um
yes and well dan feels very backgrounded
in this although i still like
um the little bit of ribbing that he and
yaz give each other over their
respective hometowns i
do like that i still like jericho as a
general presence
vinder has now just ended up
being captured and now he's just in
passenger with everybody else
and until we get a resolution on that
like and also
why
did passenger collect what was her name
diane
the the the woman that dan was supposed
to meet with
why
did swarm and as well go out of their
way to capture
her
because
that is kind of way out of their way
and i'm not saying there isn't
necessarily a reason but that's one more
thing to add to the pile of things one
would expect to get tied up in the
finale
i just don't know how there's going to
be room for plot anymore
and now we've obviously planted this
thing of the
watch that holds time lord's past and
essence which isn't working exactly as
we know it too because up to this point
that has been associated with the
chameleon arch which completely rewrites
time lords into not even being time
lords anymore and the it's not just
memories it is the entire time lord
essence because it's not just like
the way it's been depicted up to now is
that that watch doesn't just hold their
memories they're not even time lords
so like they're human they could die as
people until they get that essence back
so now it's being used just to house
memories which
i mean i could buy you modify it to just
do that i'd suppose but
theoretically the doctor's going to get
all
their missing memories back next episode
one way or another so that's a whole
other bunch of stuff to cover like
the next episode is going to have to
find a way to juggle
dealing with the events of the flux
um trying to undo it presumably whatever
the heck the grand serpent is doing and
why
again if people picked up why he matter
well what he's trying to accomplish and
why he matters to this story
i haven't caught it
and so there's that to deal with
there's a azul and swarm and
passenger and whatever is going on there
so now we finally tied in um i forget
his name i'm sorry the guy digging all
the tunnels
and so he was digging these tunnels and
connecting to other worlds did he just
know
to do that
is that something we could expect to get
answered or is that just going to get
glossed over like
the fact that
dan yaz and jericho got out of the town
i'm not even that upset
at this point
i'm just perplexed
and i keep coming back to the same thing
if this is meant to be a continuous
story
which of these stories is the main one
because i feel like the threat of the
flux the threat of
swarm and
azure azure azul i can't remember now
i've been saying one of them was one of
them's been wrong but the threat of
those two and the doctor trying to
uncover her own memories are have all
been jockeying for primary story
position
and
in and of itself that's fine and then
the other stuff can be secondary the
grand serpent could be secondary the
stuff with the santarans could be
secondary
but i still need to connect to the other
stuff going on because otherwise it's
just
stories happening in the same space and
that's really what the santarans feel
like at this point i mean we'll see
we'll see if more comes of it but it
really does feel like the entire
sontaran invasion
despite it being the episode that of
like the best so far this series is just
a thing that is happening in the same
space as everything else
and i still don't know
how
um
what's her name bell
ties into any of this
um
and vinder's just kind of been along for
the ride and i've liked him as a
character but again just kind of there
i don't
at this point i don't understand
why all of these plot threads are
occupying space in the same story
and i don't know how one
less than 60 minute episode is going to
be able to pull them all together
when their connections have been so
tenuous for five episodes
i mean i i honestly don't know
will it pull them all together i hope so
but
i have a hard time envisioning how
i guess we'll find out next time
the whole thing to me right now is
it's not even upsetting it's just weird
i feel like any one of these
things that are jockeying for primary
story status
could have supported
a six episode
connected series
but
none of them are being focused on
primarily it's jumping between them
and doing things that
the show is making
seem like they're momentous like tech
tyun showing up like there's this big
musical sting but
all we've done is heard about you once
and now you're dead
okay
i i just don't know
like that's the phrase i keep repeating
i just don't know
at this point
i'm not sure what it's doing and with
now killing off a character that like
chibnall
introducing the idea of and then
physically bringing in and then killing
off tech tyun
reminds me of the frustration i had with
moffitt
having
galafrey go off into this little pocket
dimension and implying that it will take
the doctor ages and ages and ages to
find it
um and then having gallifrey show up
again in a story that isn't actually
about finding gallifrey again
hellbent in that case and my frustration
with okay you set this thing up and then
you like
toss away the payoff as if it was a
plotline you didn't want to deal with
i'm feeling that with this techn thing
with chimnal but chimnel's doing it in
an even tighter and more compressed time
space of time the moffat did it
i
i would like nothing more
than for the next episode
to pull everything together and make me
go
oh
that's why this thing was structured
this way that's why this stuff was
wasn't tied together more cleanly until
now and
to be fair
i've had shows surprise me that way
before i've had shows pull off stuff
that i did not think it was possible to
pull off and find ways to do things that
i didn't think of i'm not i don't claim
to be
that amazing a writer
a good professional team of writers or
an individual writer
should be able to think of better things
than i can and think of solutions that i
can't
so i am still gonna hope for that
but the reality still is i don't
i don't know if i could see
anybody pulling together all these
threads in one episode
which brings me back to what i said
before i don't think the question is how
does he tie all this off the question is
how many of these plot threads just get
dropped and ignored and or punted to be
dealt with in the specials
i think there's only so many times you
can do that
so many times you can
promise major answers and then kick the
can down the road
i think you can only do that so much
i don't know
we'll be back in a week
we'll see
yeah
that's kind of all i've got
survivors of the flux
what do people think about this
whatever your thoughts are positive
negative whatever they are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it like share subscribe i
have a patreon that is how i pay the
bills and it keeps this entire operation
up and running any amount you are able
to help is greatly appreciated no big
pressure though
i uh i do my best to try and keep things
relaxed around here
and ultimately at the end of the day you
are the council
and i'm just running the meetings
so until next time
this council
is adjourned
[Music]
hey if you're sticking around through
the credits might as well hear some
names read out my patreon helps support
this and in particular i want to thank
raven mcbain bookworm mj tracy scrabbit
vincent paul bartolucci kailyn schwartz
edelman robin moore ross schultz shayla
gourlay wanna hear me mispronounce your
name check out the rewards on the
patreon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now
[Music]